bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du camping cap le plus cher au monde
alors si vous avez un permis b par
tendent à voir avec votre copine car je
pense que celui là vous avez oublié
parce qu'il faut un permis poids lourd
et c'est une bête de compétition et en
plus vous avez un hélico dessus
[Musique]
on n'aime pas mal
double
le camping car le plus cher du monde
vous avez que les cuisines de fous
furieux complètement équipée avec frigo
four hotte aspirante fait juste dingue
[Musique]
mais regardez le salon télé nous avons
en dessous
la fois su éliminer pour les hivers un
peu rude bien évidemment la cave à vin
parce qu'il faut pas se priver le petit
canapé à la cool pour se reposer on
s'arrête au cap d'agde après une soirée
bien sympathique entre amis on a le
petit canapé à la cool alors les
toilettes sont ici et la douche la
chambre regardez la chambre
[Musique]
avec miroir qu'on se demande bien
pourquoi ils nous ont collé un miroir là
allez savoir petites chambres cosy avec
télé bien évidemment on peut mettre une
petite lumière si vous voulez pour la
déco alors là la finition laisse un
petit peu à désirer que je
recommanderais pas celui-là titre vue
sur l'extérieur pour voir le lever du
jour où la plage
bon pourquoi pas bien évidemment grande
vue plongeante sur le reste du corps
pink à ma foi fort sympathique et
maintenant on va aller voir le must la
terrasse et du monde dans mon camping
car je suis désolé mais pas si je vais
l'acheter sur notre autre monde
j'imagine mm à le prix de l'ange
ça donne jusqu'au d une fortune là on
monte sur la terrasse
tous ces revers
mais beau
jolie petite terrasse avec le jacuzzi
mais surtout de dingue c'est quand vous
faites un peu chiant votre camping car
et que vous voulez changer de spots vous
avez qu à prendre l'hélicoptère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand vous avez fini votre soirée au cap
d'agde nous allons un peu ras-le-bol
gibbons on s'est bien amusé et d'en
faire un tour en hélico ça c'est quand
même un truc de dingue
l'hélico son nom compliqué j'avais pas
pensé avant mais maintenant vous le
dites achetez que le frère vous avez ici
bien évidemment le petit jacques houde
ce ne serait pas marrant avec les petits
fauteuils arrière
bon voilà j'étais très heureux de
partager avec vous mon nouveau camping
car bien évidemment je vous inviterai
ont tiré sur des balais ensemble
attendant que c'est vraiment un truc de
dingue j'imagine même pas compris
l'énormité du truc
bien évidemment certains poids lourds
mais pour nos petites soirées d'hiver je
vous ferai la popote quand on ira se bat
et tous ensemble
alors qu'est ce qu'ils font dans le
frigo vous inquiétez pas vraiment un
truc de fou même le côté conducteur est
juste
tingaud
c'est vraiment produit de youtube sont
disponibles et puis je vais pas
l'acheter de toute façon il n'est pas à
vendre
mais dites-moi quand même ce que vous en
pensez en commentaire est ce que vous
vous verriez vous partir en vacances
dans un camping car comme ça est ce que
vous faites du camping car et est ce que
vous trouvez pas d'un camping car avec
ce type de produits s'est pas
complètement dingue marqué - tout ça en
commentaire j'ai hâte de savoir trois
ans et puis pourquoi pas après tout on
pourrait se nouer pour une petite virée
au cap d'agde et pour pourrait se marier
avec des potes soirée champagne ont fait
monter du monde et après on fait une
petite virée en hélico ou jusqu'à
montpellier et là c'est la grosse teuf
c'est la folie bon merci de regarder la
vidéo je vous dis à très très bientôt
restez connectés parce qu'à encore plein
de levante plein de trucs de dingue à
voir moi je vous embrasse
je vous dis à bientôt
[Musique]